[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute mache ich endlich
wackler war und zwar ganz einfach für
anfänger sehr gut geeignet und zwar ich
denke baklava kind jeder das ist dieses
süßgebäck aus dem orient mit viele teig
diesen ganzen tag fäden butter und
müssen und in wochen wie gesagt nur vier
zutaten zeit brauchen wir eigentlich
kaum weniger als eine stunde sind dort
schon fertig und ich zeige euch jetzt
zuallererst die zutaten
wir benötigen walnüsse die werde ich
gleich noch fein mahlen außerdem sind
also sind es auch nur optional nur wenn
dir das mögt butter die habe ich bereits
geschmolzen und die wichtigste zutat das
ist dieser viele ideen findet ihr in
jedem türkischen oder arabischen
supermarkt und zwar in der kühl
abteilung ich beginne jetzt zuallererst
mit der walnuss schicht ihr könnt
natürlich auch jede andere art von ist
nehmen das ist vollkommen euch
überlassen aber walnüsse sind so typisch
und schmecken auch super lecker jetzt
gibt hierzu allererste mainzer kleinere
und wird sie dann so einigermaßen fein
mahlen und jetzt würde ich das ganze um
in eine schüssel und gibt den zimt dazu
und dann wird das ganze gut verrührt
ich habe da jetzt rein gegeben obwohl
ich nicht der größte fan bin denn am
ende schmeckt man ihm ziemlich so sehr
aus aber es gibt trotzdem eine
orientalische note also falls ihr auch
keine cent wert gibt es trotzdem gerne
mit rein und jetzt machen wir weiter mit
unseren piloten hole ich gerade aus der
verpackung und dann wird er erstmal
zurechtgeschnitten mein verteilt habe
ich mir jetzt auf ein großes
schneidebrett gelegt damit ich mir die
arbeitsfläche nicht kaputt machen
und jetzt ist die form ganz wichtig ist
müssen wir zuallererst die form
ausschneiden aus dem feiertag ich habe
jetzt hier so eine runde form genommen
ihr könnt auch einige nehmen ganz wie
ihr möchtet und jetzt einfach darauf
geben und den umriss einmal komplett
ausschneiden und sobald ihr das dann
ausgeschnitten habt gibt dir das an die
seite und versucht dann eventuell wenn
es klappt also wenn der platz ist noch
mal die runde form auszuschneiden
ansonsten könnt ihr aber auch das
beliebig groß schneiden denn wir geben
so wie du am ende den ganzen viel teig
in die auflaufform es wird also nichts
verschwendet
ich habe mir zu viele kreise wie möglich
aus dem kino teig aus geschnitten jetzt
ja gesehen es geht auch wenn ich zwei
halbkreise nimmt und den restlichen vier
bloß nicht wegwerfen denn wie gesagt den
verwenden wir ebenfalls weiter die tun
mir dann dazwischen dann sieht es auch
keiner so weitergeht wir brauchen auch
nicht mehr lange versprochen ich habe
jetzt hier wie gesagt die runde form ihr
könnt auch jeglicher anraten von
auflaufform verwenden und ich geh jetzt
zuallererst auf den boden und an die
seiten reichlich butter und jetzt fangen
wir an mit dem schichten falls ihr doch
ein bisschen länger braucht und euch
zeit lasst dann legt auf jeden fall ein
sauberes küchentuch auf die viele
blätter denn die trockenen wirklich sehr
schnell aus ich stehe hier zuallererst
mit den schönen runden in die mitte
kommen dann die die nicht so schön sind
und zum abschluss wieder die runden
blätter und jetzt gibt dir immer zwei
viele blätter übereinander und dann gibt
er erst wieder butter darüber
die enden jetzt nicht so schön waren vom
die tu ich schon immer gern so in die
mitte das sieht man auch nicht also auch
nicht am anstieg macht euch da gar keine
sorgen versteckt die einfach so ein
bisschen
ich hatte noch nie selbst gemachten
dabei ist ehrlich das ist meine kollegen
braucht stimmen letztens habe ich ihn zu
euch mitgebracht da was zu arbeiten dann
bei dem mit deiner familie gegessen auch
so
ja warum ich so jetzt habe ich die
hälfte des tages in der form und hier
müssen wir an unsere füllung denken denn
die musste er auch noch verstaut werden
aber ich wollte ich noch ganz prozent
abgeben wenn ihr die füllung rein macht
dann nimmt wieder diese ganz normalen
rotalge die in einem stück sind so
wieder zwei stück dann butter drauf und
dann die füllung da reingehen
sobald die füllung gut verteilt wurde
den wir wieder zwei glatte und gerade
viele blätter drauf ohne butter und
geben dann erst die butter drauf wenn
die x2 viele blätter eben übereinander
gestapelt wurden
jetzt habe ich alles geschichtet und
hier oben habe ich noch keine butter
drauf er hat jetzt zwei optionen
entweder ergibt ganz normale schicht
butter drauf wie gehabt oder aber das
lege ich euch sehr ans herz benutzt
nämlich auch die ganzen baklava läden
die nehmen immer dieses butter geht und
das gebe ich jetzt oben drauf ich nehme
da jetzt ein bisschen was raus schmeckt
ist eben eine mikrowelle und es gibt
noch mal so ein richtig schönes
typisches aroma und dann habt ihr diesen
effekt wenn eure gäste probieren und die
probieren und sagen hast das gekaufte da
selber gemacht pro witzenhausen vertraut
mir
und jetzt zeige ich euch noch eine
möglichkeit wie ihr euer baklava
durchschneiden können
wichtig ist nur dass sie es nicht bis
zum boden hin durchschneidet sondern
wirklich nur die oberfläche die ersten
vier bis fünf blätter und den rest
schneiden wir es nach dem backen durch
jetzt haben wir vier schnitte gemacht 1
2 3 und 4
und jetzt nehmen wir uns jeweils ein
viertel und schneiden hier noch mal
senkrecht dreimal ein das heißt 123 und
dann auf der anderen seite noch mal 123
nachdem wir alles durchgeschnitten haben
geht es wieder um dieses ursprungs
dreieck und jetzt müssen wir noch mal
senkrecht einschneiden das heißt wir
schneiden hier den ersten ein
hier kommt auch nur ein stück bei raus
hier seht ihr das ist unser erstes stück
hier lassen wir schon etwas mehr abstand
hier haben wir dann zwei stücke das sind
die zwei stücke und jetzt schneiden wir
hier noch einmal ein und jetzt seht ihr
so ein bisschen das muster das ist ein
stück hier sind zwei hier sind drei und
hier sind vier und jetzt gehts hier mit
der anderen hälfte des dreiecks weiter
das muster ist fertig man offen ist auch
schon vorgeheizt auf 150 grad ober und
unterhitze und jetzt könnt ihr das ist
nur optional aber die blätter werden an
der oberfläche gleich noch richtig
aufgehen
deshalb könnt ihr jetzt ein bisschen
leitungswasser nehmen und dann mit den
händen so ein bisschen nass machen aber
auch nicht zu viel nur ein bisschen und
dann gebe ich dass sie den ofen und
jetzt wird unser baklava ganz langsam
gebacken wie schon gesagt bei 150 grad
ober und unterhitze für 40 bis 45
minuten bis es richtig schön goldbraun
ist werden unser butler war jetzt im
ofen schön lecker vor sich hin was zeige
ich euch die zutaten für unser
zuckersirup wir benötigen ganz klassisch
wasser zucker und einen spritzer
zitronensaft jetzt gebe ich in einen
kleinen topf wasser und zucker für das
um und lässt das kurz aufkochen und weil
wir einen dünnflüssigen zuckersirup
benötigen lassen wir das auch nur eine
minute lang köcheln und nicht länger die
minute ist rum und jetzt gehen wir noch
den spritzer zitronensaft rein oder ist
auch ganz wichtig darauf dürften nicht
verzichten liegen die zuckerkristalle
nochmals gut umrühren
dann wird der zucker sirup einmal
umgeschichtet und dann warten wir
eigentlich nur auf unser baklava
mein papa war hat ganz genau 45 minuten
gebraucht uns richtig schön goldbraun
und jetzt kommt unser zuckersirup ins
spiel
es gibt da verschiedene theorien so kann
sie rhythmus heißt sein oder kalt und
ausgepackt aber ich mache es so ich
nehms direkt aus dem ofen und gäbe dann
wird's lauwarme bis ihr abgekühlte kalte
den zuckersirup daraufhin zwischen
versprecher gehabt
wir gehen wir das jetzt da drauf und
lassen es dann noch mal vollständig aus
kommt er wie das wieder durchschneiden
und falls euch der bagger war auch so
ein bisschen hoch gestiegen ist und in
sich ein bisschen luft gebildet das ist
ganz normal
ihr könnt es anschließend könnt ihr euch
so ein anwender nehmen oder irgendwas
flach ist und ganz leicht drauf drücken
dann entweicht die luft auch also nur
wenn euch das stört so und jetzt lassen
wir den zuckersirup einziehen
das dauert ein bisschen nachdem das
alles ein bisschen heruntergekühlt ist
gebe ich das auch in den kühlschrank und
dann schneiden wir die reform noch mal
nach das bak klar war durfte bei mir
jetzt im kühlschrank drei stunden lang
kühlen
und jetzt ist es soweit jetzt können wir
die form nach schneiden und direkt
servieren
[Musik]
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr das
baklava rezept nach macht alle genauen
mengenangaben stehen unten in der
infobox
ansonsten könnt ihr mich gerne wieder
auf insider mit dem hashtag iges kitchen
unter eurem fotos markieren und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen gönnt euch mal was süßes und
ich sag bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis
kitchen
das ist echt ich den ernst
jetzt überlegt was zu essen sollte
dieses gekaufte zeug oder meine tollen
baklava erzählt deine baklava konnte
sich das jetzt komme
[Musik]